cuéntenos Qué se sabe de la operación
del dinero es decir cuánto es cuando lo
tendrían disponible y Cómo se elige En
qué invertirlo
Buenas noches un placer saludarles lo
primero es entender que es un fondo que
pudiera estar pivotando entre 2.800
millones de dólares y según conocimos
hoy pudiera llegar a ser hasta cinco mil
millones de dólares que claramente
pudieran estar en periodo de hasta tres
años entrando administrados a través de
la ONU y de diferentes agencias de la
ONU específicamente para atender
inicialmente temas ligados a la
estabilización de los hospitales o el
tema ligado a la salud al tema ligado a
la educación claramente hay una
prioridad importante parte importante
del programa de alimentos sobre todo
para atender a poblaciones mayores de
edad porque inicialmente estuvo
concentrada esta ayuda humanitaria que
menores de edad y entrar también de
manera significativa en la
estabilización de servicios públicos
principalmente en el tema eléctrico pero
también entendiendo que hay que atender
son vulnerables que recientemente por el
tema de las lluvias resultaron bastantes
afectadas eh Y y allí quizá hay un
esfuerzo importante para tratar de hacer
esfuerzo para lograr ese tema de generar
una relocalización de personas o tratar
de generar sistemas eléctricas Bueno
pero el tema central de las
negociaciones son las elecciones
generales de 2024 porque la oposición
quiere garantías para participar
Mientras que el presidente maduro aspira
a tener un respiro económico Que suba su
popularidad en este sentido como el
acuerdo de hoy impactaría en las
votaciones
Mira para Nicolás Maduro claramente
pudiera ser favorecido por estos tramos
si bien Tú tienes un tramo que pudiera
estar derivado de toda esta ayuda de
estos fondos bloqueados la realidad es
que debido a la licencia que le amplía
Chevron la capacidad de operación y la
capacidad de venta directa o de llevar
petróleo Estados Unidos pudiera por
temas indirectos favorecer a Nicolás
Maduro ahora la popularidad de Maduro
que hoy es 20% de acuerdo a los datos de
rc consultores del frijol que es la
encuestadora que está midiendo este tema
pudiera llevar a Nicolás Maduro a Elevar
al menos en 10-15 puntos porcentuales
esa evaluación de gestión el tema es que
no va a ser inmediato pudiéramos estar
viendo los primeros resultados por lo
menos en abril o junio del año que viene
debido que muchos de estos fondos pasan
por procesos licitatorios por procesos
de descongelamiento de fondos
directamente desde los fax del
departamento del tesoro norteamericano
así como los entendimientos que pueda
haber entre las partes o posición y
gobierno
con las agencias de Naciones Unidas